la investigación continúa el gobierno
canadiense anunció una nueva búsqueda de
restos indígenas en la escuela
residencial del instituto moha que hoy
estamos aquí para comenzar la búsqueda
de más verdad
que se extenderá a una mayor educación y
conciencia y que con suerte traerá un
cierre para las familias y comunidades
que han extrañado a sus seres queridos
durante tanto tiempo
la escuela se encuentra en ontario al
este del país y fue dirigida por
anglicanos desde mediados del siglo 19
hasta 1970 en dichos recintos se han
reportado hasta el momento 54 fallecidos
pero con las nuevas labores de rastreo
por parte de la policía canadiense dicha
cifra podría aumentar la fase 1 de la
búsqueda de los motivos de los niños
desaparecidos comienza hoy después de un
trabajo muy avanzado realizado por los
supervivientes las secretarias
supervivientes y el grupo operativo
conjunto quienes alguna vez caminaron
por ese recinto siendo estudiantes ahora
se convierten en una ficha clave para
las investigaciones que este martes dan
un paso para esclarecer unos hechos que
permanecen borrosos traerá un cierre
para mucha de nuestra gente para muchos
de nuestros mayores muchos de ellos se
llevaron sus secretos y su dolor a la
tumba
durante 165 años el sistema de escuelas
residenciales en canadá separó a miles
de niños indígenas de sus familias y
eran obligados a abandonar sus creencias
y su propio idioma en octubre el
vaticano anunció que el papa francisco
viajará al territorio canadiense en
diciembre una visita en la que se
esperan las disculpas formales del sumo
pontífice sobre los abusos cometidos
contra los niños indígenas en dicho país